[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans auditions
publiques toute l'équipe évidemment
d'auditions publiques vous présente ses
meilleurs vœux pour l'année 2023 une
année qui commence sur les chapeaux de
roue avec la réforme des retraites
présentées demain par Elisabeth borne
quel sera la position finale du parti LR
ce sera déterminant pour le gouvernement
et sans doute aussi pour l'avenir de la
droite bonjour Aurélien Pradier bonsoir
merci d'être avec nous que vous avez 36
ans vous êtes député du Lot actuel
secrétaire général des républicains
arrivée troisième dans la course à la
présidence du parti derrière Éric Ciotti
et Bruno Retailleau Éric Ciotti qui
s'apprêterait à vous nommer Aurélien
Pradier vice-président délégué ce qui
ferait de vous le numéro 2 curieux
d'attelage pourrait-on dire avec Eric
Chiotti puisque vous refusez jusqu'à
maintenant
qu'on touche à l'âge légal de la
retraite quand lui serait prêt à voter
le recul à 64 ans est allé sur 10 ans il
y a serez-vous un facteur de division
chez LR ou alors avez-vous mis de l'eau
dans votre vin on aimerait le savoir
évidemment à la fin de cette émission
elle a l'air assurera-t-elle à sura-t-il
une majorité au gouvernement la réforme
des retraites ce sera le plat de
résistance si vous permettez de
l'émission mais pas seulement menu il y
aura évidemment d'autres sujets que vous
traiterez dans quelques instants avec
Brigitte Boucher est un traduit Marion
Mourgue qui est sans doute une des
meilleures expertes de la droite grand
reporter au Figaro vous posera des
questions sur précisément l'avenir de la
droite Vincent roux vous posera des
questions d'actualité et enfin vous avez
accepté et on vous en remercie un débat
avec Pierre Laurence sénateur communiste
mon petit doigt me dit qu'elle reviendra
aussi sur cette question des retraites
et les importantes la votre vous cette
réforme d'abord sur le fond Aurélien
Pradier permettez-moi une petite
question
êtes-vous toujours opposé à ce qu'on
touche à l'âge légal par principe ou
êtes-vous prêt à évoluer
sous certaines conditions j'ai des
convictions que je n'ai pas abandonné
que j'exprimais souvent de manière
constante et il n'y a aucune raison que
je revienne sur ces convictions là
quelles sont ses conditions j'ai dit
depuis le départ que l'âge légal ne
devait pas être l'alpha et l'oméga j'ai
dit d'ailleurs que toucher seulement à
l'âge légal était une aberration ça ne
suffisait pas réformer les retraites
j'ai dit que ce n'était pas un totem là
je légale c'est ce que la première
ministre a dit il y a quelques semaines
et donc je vous confirme 65 ans n'était
pas un tote mais moi je considère que
l'âge légal n'est pas un totem et la
vérité c'est que je n'ai pas changé
d'avis dès lors que on se contenterait
d'une réforme des retraites par le seul
âge légal on aurait une réforme
absolument bancale et donc oui toute
réforme des retraites qui ne passerait
que par le report de la géniale serait
injuste et inefficace voilà pourquoi
dans la discussion que nous allons avoir
je vais tracer les lignes rouges qui
sont les miennes que j'ai toujours
exprimées constamment sur lesquels j'ai
retravaillé avec mes collègues députés
aussi les républicains pour que nous
puissions faire corps ensemble et
j'aurai dans les qui viennent et y
compris ce soir l'occasion de dire
quelles sont les limites que je ne
souhaite pas franchir il y a une règle
simple pour moi ce qui doit primer c'est
la durée de cotisation à partir de là
tout est ouvert c'est Brigitte Boucher
est un traduit je pense vont
effectivement explorer la question et
ainsi que Marion bon que ça sera très
intéressant de connaître vos lignes
rouges mais ce que je déforme votre
pensée si je dis qu'à certaines
conditions vous pourriez accepter qu'on
touche à l'âge légal comprenons-nous
bien quel est le problème de l'âge légal
le problème de l'âge légal et qu'il va
le report de las légal va punir celles
et ceux qui ont commencé à travailler
tôt je veux que la droite et pas
seulement la droite d'ailleurs que nous
défendions dans ce pays plus fortement
les travailleurs prenons l'exemple
simple de celui qui aura commencé à
travailler à 20 ans si demain on allonge
l'âge légal à 64 ans ou 65 ans mais même
64 ans il va devoir travailler 43
annuités de cotisations allez donc
jusqu'à 63 ans c'est la réforme Touraine
aujourd'hui celui qui aura commencé à
travailler à 20 ans on va
raisonnablement lui demander de
travailler une année de plus pour
financer le système je considère que
c'est un juste longue et vous allez nous
dire
que la durée de cotisation pour ceux qui
ont commencé à travailler tôt prime sur
l'âge légal je vous l'expliquerai mais
pardon je suis un peu entêté mais je
n'irai pas au-delà mais je repose ma
question simplement qu'on puisse
comprendre quelles sont vos bornes si
les conditions pour vous sont remplies
de protéger tous ceux qui pourraient
toucher par le l'âge légal est-ce que si
ces conditions sont remplies vous êtes
d'accord mais nous en sommes encore un
peu loin et encore un long chemin il y a
un chemin et bien on peut trouver un
chemin
portée serait celle que je défends
depuis des années oui mais pardon de
vous dire que sur ce sujet les détails
ne sont pas des détails ils sont
essentiels et dans les lignes rouges que
je fixerai tout à l'heure qui ne sont
pas des lubies qui sont des vrais
convictions pour respecter les
travailleurs le compte n'y est pas
aujourd'hui et si le compte n'y est pas
Elisabeth Martichoux il n'y a aucune
raison que je vote une réforme injuste à
laquelle je ne croirais pas mais si le
quantillet votez cette réforme ce serait
passé un accord avec le gouvernement
mais le cœur de la politique c'est de
faire en sorte que ses propres idées
s'imposent aux autres si les idées que
je porte avec mes amis je ne suis pas le
seul à le faire demain s'impose dans
cette réforme alors tant mieux je mets
en garde y compris ma propre famille
politique il n'est pas question que par
cette réforme des retraites nous
rendrions dans quel cas de gouvernement
que ce soit et je crains que certains
qui nous veulent du mal tentent de faire
en sorte que nous ayons un accord un peu
rapide sur cette réforme des retraites
chez nous seulement mais ceux qui
veulent partir en macronie un peu vite
peut-être la macronienne même espérer
que nous ayons ici un accord de
gouvernement il n'y aura pas cette bonne
guerre que la macronie espère un accord
avec vous elle a un enjeu c'est ça
des règles très claires qui fassent que
demain si nous avons obtenu des choses
et dans l'intérêt des Français et
certainement pas pour signer un pacte
politique que je refuserai toujours
est-ce que vous regrettez l'expression
d'érections est-ce que la façon dont il
semble
d'accord pour dire pattiser il serait
pas d'accord avec ma formulation mais
trouver un accord est-ce que vous
regrettez qu'il soit sorti du bois hier
sur ce ton là
Eric Ciotti dans son rôle de président
de parti et c'est normal que lui-même
trace un premier chemin nous aurons
demain une réunion de groupe chez
moi-même rediscuté avec Eric soit il est
beaucoup plus ouvert que parfois on peut
l'imaginer et sur des sujets comme cela
nous avons des convictions communes à
chacun de faire en sorte que nous
obtenions non mais nous allons y venir
lorsque Éric Ciotti et mes amis disent
que ceux qui ont commencé à travailler
tôt doivent finir tôt alors nous sommes
sur la même ligne à moi et à d'autres de
mes amis qui avons toujours défendu ses
convictions de mettre sur la table des
choses concrètes parce que pour
l'instant on est un peu au stade de
celui qui veille sur les lignes rouges
dans cette affaire par rapport à ceux
qui voudraient éventuellement
les lignes rouges se sont mes
convictions toujours cru et auquel je
crois encore lesquels en face de vous
Brigitte Bouchet est un traduit
alors on demande dans le vif du sujet et
le détail oui alors le lien prédier vous
venez de dire que nous allons venir sur
une ligne commune avec
Eric Ciotti est-ce que finalement il y a
pas un deal pour cette place de numéro 2
des républicains est-ce que finalement
vous n'êtes pas entendu et vous allez y
arriver finalement à trouver une
position commune chez les LR truc que je
viens de tempérament dealer franchement
c'est pas vraiment de tempérament
non je suis tout à fait conforme à ce
que j'ai dit j'ai toujours dit une chose
simple que je continue à dire y compris
durant la campagne que je voulais que
ceux qui ont commencé tôt finissent tôt
que je refusais catégoriquement que par
le seul âge légal on porte cette réforme
des retraites dès lors que demain nous
obtenions nous obtiendrions dans cette
réforme là des lignes rouges qui sont
catégoriques pour moi et pour mes amis
d'abord la revalorisation des petites
retraites j'insiste sur ce point les
nouveaux entrants en retraite les 1200
euros garantis mais aussi celles et ceux
qui sont déjà en situation de retraite
ça c'est une condition précédente pour
moi une condition sinequanone pour les
carrières pleines évidemment pour ceux
qui ont travaillé toute leur vie il
n'est pas question d'avoir encore dans
notre pays des retraites ending
inférieures à 1200 euros la mesure
l'évaluer c'est au-delà de milliards
d'euros mais la vérité oui mais la
vérité c'est que c'est un enjeu de
justice et de dignité absolument
fondamentale je le vois tous les jours
ça représente parce qu'il y a 5 millions
de personnes qui n'ont pas
la retraite à 1000 euros et mais pour
que ce soit des carrières pleines on
sait que ça représente relativement pour
le monde tout à fait honnête les
chiffrages sont difficiles à avoir ce
qui est certain c'est que l'enjeu il est
plus pour celles et ceux qui sont déjà
en retraite que pour celles et ceux qui
vont y entrer parce que la génération de
mes parents et mes grands-parents sont
ceux qui ont été le plus soumis à des
carrières hachées pas toujours déclaré
parfois des niveaux de revenus très bas
la vérité c'est que progressivement dans
notre pays le temps de travail la
protection sociale a évalué et donc les
nouveaux entrants seront en réalité
plutôt aux 1200 euros l'enjeu il est
pour celles et ceux qui sont déjà en
retraite moi je ne transigerai pas
d'ailleurs non plus le deuxième
préalable pour moi sont les carrières
des femmes nous en parlons peu mais la
réforme des retraites notamment celle-ci
va être très injuste pour les femmes
dont le niveau de et globalement plus
bas durant toute leur carrière par
rapport aux hommes et qui rentre dans la
vie active plus tard parce qu'elles ont
des enfants et elles élèvent leurs
enfants et elles font de les familles
elles ont des carrières hachées elles
ont des carrières et pour l'instant nous
n'avons pas solutions je souhaite donc
être très précis je souhaite demain que
le congé parental soit totalement prise
en compte dans la cotisation les
cotisations retraite je souhaite aussi
que pour chaque enfant
si c'est dans le projet du gouvernement
tant mieux on le soutiendrons mais je
lâcherai pas sur ce sujet parce que
c'est absolument fondamental j'ajoute un
troisième point ce troisième point c'est
de m'assurer que toutes celles et ceux
qui ont commencé à travailler avant 21
ans bénéficie ou du régime de carrière
longue c'est le cas aujourd'hui pour
ceux qui ont commencé avant 18 ans ou
avant 16 ans mais nous avons un problème
nous avons un problème avec ceux qui
seront à l'âge de 20 ans qui ont
commencé à cotiser à 20 ans qui auront
43 annuités de cotisation comme la
réforme Touraine ne nécessite
aujourd'hui qui pourrait donc finir leur
carrière professionnelle prendre leur
retraite à 63 ans avec un report de
l'âge légal injustement on va demander à
ceux qui travaillent le plus dur de
travailler une année de plus pour les
autres c'est insupportable et voilà la
raison pour laquelle je propose au
gouvernement que nous avons sur ce sujet
je souhaite que la durée de cotisation
l'emporte sur l'âge légal pour tous ceux
qui ont commencé à travailler avec 20
ans et c'est pour moi une condition
fondamentale c'est au fond on les avait
une partie chaud vous m'interrogez tout
à l'heure ce que j'ai toujours dit si la
durée de cotisation écrase l'âge légal
alors il n'y a plus de sujet avec l'âge
légal c'est ce qui permettrait de mieux
respecter une durée plus d'âge légal
pour vous maintenant nous sur la durée
de cotisation de la réforme Touraine
c'est l'horizon des 43 agites
années de cotisations j'ai toujours dit
que c'est la durée de cotisation qui
devait l'emporter sur l'âge légal et
aujourd'hui le problème que nous avons
c'est qu'il y a un creux entre ceux qui
peuvent bénéficier des carrières il faut
améliorer je ferai des propositions
moi-même et mes amis mais on voit bien
qu'au fond dans cette réforme il y a une
astuce l'astuce c'est de faire payer la
réforme des retraites à ceux qui ont
commencé à travailler à 20 ans et ceux
qui ont commencé à travailler en même
temps sont les catégories les plus
populaires les plus travailleurs je
refuse que cette réforme des retraites
tape sur les travailleurs voilà pourquoi
je pose cette proposition sur la table
je l'ai fait en décembre auprès de mes
amis députés les républicains je le
ferai demain en réunion de groupe et
pour moi c'est une ligne rouge donc on
va parler tout à l'heure d'un accord de
gouvernement vous n'en voulez pas vous
ne souhaitez pas que il y a un accord de
gouvernement même si la droite est
Renaissance la majorité se rejoignent
sur cette réforme si c'est un texte
budgétaire un plfssr comme on dit un
texte budgétaire ça veut dire quoi que
si on vote ce texte on est dans la
majorité si on le vote pas on n'est pas
on est contre je souhaite simplement que
nous mesurions à quel point une réforme
des retraites c'est pas une réforme
paramétrique comme une autre la réforme
des retraites c'est un un vrai sujet de
société c'est une vraie réforme de
société qui va changer la vie de nos
concitoyens
voter une réforme des retraites avec
laquelle nous aurions des points de
désaccord majeurs parce que on
considérait qu'il faut la voter pour je
ne sais quelle raison d'affichage
politique alors oui c'est faire en sorte
que nous participions à une réforme
injuste je refuse cohérence non
candidats à la présidence de la
République LR ont tous plaidé pour un
recul à 65 ou 64 ans
les deux derniers candidats qu'ils l'ont
fait ont perdu et lorsque je porte pour
cette raison là
je pense que lorsqu'on résume une
réforme des retraites au report de l'âge
légal on va pénaliser celles et ceux qui
travaillent durent dans notre pays et si
la droite vous le voyez bien
progressivement depuis des années s'est
éloigné des catégories populaires de
celles et ceux qui produisent le plus
d'efforts pour notre pays c'est aussi à
force d'avoir des réformes qui n'étaient
que technique alors oui nous pourrions
avancer sur cette réforme des retraites
mais voyez-vous les trois conditions que
j'ai posées là elles sont déjà
absolument majeures et je le dis à les
aimait de bornes pour un mon nom et au
nom de plusieurs de mes collègues je
l'ai dit à erichiotti d'ailleurs sur ces
sujets-là si nous voulons avancer sur
cette réforme il va falloir aller plus
loin première question vous êtes combien
sur cette ligne au sein du groupe LR à
l'Assemblée aujourd'hui mais je pense
que nous sommes très majoritaires et
d'ailleurs mais même eriki sur votre lit
une raison simple c'est que lorsque y
compris le président de notre famille
politique dit que il ne veut pas que
celles et ceux qui ont commencé tôt soit
les dindons de la farce il a raison la
proposition que je fais elle vient
concrétiser tout cela parce que vous
voyez depuis quelques jours on lance des
grandes phrases on dit qu'on veut un
geste pour les petites retraites non pas
un geste on veut que les petites
retraites actuelles soit à 1200 euros on
dit il faut mieux prendre en compte les
carrières non soyons précis il faut que
ceux qui ont commencé à travailler avant
21 ans est une prime qui est liée la
durée de cotisation vous avez la durée
de cotisation vous pouvez continuer si
vous le voulez vous aurez une majoration
mais on vous permet aussi de vous
arrêter je vais insister sur ce point
j'ai souvent cité ce chiffre et ça
m'étonne qui ne soit pas plus cité 8
milliards d'euros 8 milliards d'euros
c'est ce que nous consacrons chaque
année à financer des pensions
d'invalidité les pensions navalidité
elles sont pas liées seulement à des
abus elles sont liés majoritairement à
des femmes et des hommes qui ont
commencé à travailler dur et tôt et qui
ne peuvent pas aller jusqu'au bout j'ai
pris durant la campagne interne des
républicains l’exemple de mon frère
boulanger les boulangers sont très très
en ce moment comment voulez-vous
expliquer à mon frère qui se lève à
minuit et demi tous les matins pour
aller bosser qui a commencé à cotiser à
20 ans que demain il va devoir cotiser
davantage pour le système c'est pas
possible et ce n'est pas conforme pour
revenir à ce que vous évoquiez Elisabeth
Martichoux à l'idée que je me fais d'une
droite qui respecte la valeur travail
fonce que je dis est très cohérent avec
ce que je voudrais les seniors parce que
c'est le gouvernement envisage de mettre
en place un index sur l'emploi des
seniors sur le modèle de ce qui existe
aujourd'hui plusieurs matières d'égalité
professionnelle entre les hommes et les
femmes est-ce que c'est une bonne mesure
est-ce que c'est suffisant pour vous
mais c'est très insuffisant ce qu'on a
besoin d'un nouveau thermomètre non
enfin on connaît la situation nous
sommes un des pays d'Europe dans lequel
le taux d'emploi des seniors est un des
plus bas c'est d'ailleurs tout l'enjeu
lorsque je dis que le seul report
mécanique de l'âge légal ne suffit pas
c'est parce que c'est illusoire de
croire qu'avec la seule mesure de l'âge
on va faire travailler les Français plus
longtemps donc que faut-il faire est-ce
qu'il faut sanctionner les entreprises
qui ne suffira pas de se débarrasse des
seniors ça ne suffira pas ce qu'il faut
c'est deux choses ce qu'il faut c'est
faire en sorte que les seigneurs
puissent travailler plus longtemps et
donc aménager les fins de carrière faire
en sorte que ça existe dans d'autres
pays d'Europe on puisse travailler un
peu moins sur la fin de sa carrière
continuez à cotiser pleinement et être
une ressource nouvelle
sortir pour le travail
qui fonctionnent très bien parce que un
des défis de cette réforme des retraites
c'est qu'on pourra toujours
éternellement reporter légal si l'écart
entre l'âge légal et l'effectivité de la
fin du travail est toujours aussi grand
ça ne sert à rien deuxième chose
lesquels si on repousse l'âge légal
mécaniquement ça repousse l'âge de
départ non pas totalement en réalité
puisque lorsque l'on rencontre mais
c'est très marginal les entreprises
la meilleure manière de faire en sorte
que nous puissions sauver notre système
de retraite c'est de s'assurer que
lorsqu'on est en bonne santé en pleine
forme on travaille davantage voilà
pourquoi dans le brouhaha ambiant j'ai
proposé en décembre que la droite
travaille sur la semaine de 38 heures au
lieu des 35 ou 36 heures aujourd'hui sur
quatre jours ce qui correspond pour moi
à l'effort nécessaire de travailler
davantage donc de cotiser davantage mais
aussi à l'aménagement du temps de
travail à la société que nous
connaissons aujourd'hui c'est conforme à
deux objectifs travailler plus et
travailler mieux j'ajoute un point on
oublie de dire que pour mieux financer
notre système de retraite il va falloir
faire aussi le ménage dans tous les
régimes spéciaux dans la disparité qu'il
y a entre le régime du public et du
privé je suis favorable à ce qu'on est
la même règle entre le privé et le
public je souhaite que ce soit les 25
dernières années qui comptent mais ça
veut dire qu'il va falloir aller voir
nos amis nous fonctionnaires en leur
disant que désormais les primes devront
être intégrés à leur salaire et que si
ces primes là sont intégrés à leur
salaire alors on va pouvoir leur
demander un effort supplémentaire qui
d'être calé sur les 25 dernières années
comme dans le privé
que cette réforme ne s'appliquerait
qu'aux nouveaux entrants nous avons
besoin de justice dans cette réforme là
il faut donc que nous allions très
au-delà de la clause du grand-père parce
que les régimes spéciaux sont
aujourd'hui des régimes qui nourrissent
une injustice ou un sentiment
d'injustice faisons en sorte aussi
pardon d'insister que il y ait moins
d'emplois vacants les quatre à 500 000
emplois vacants nous avons dans les
secteurs en tension ce sont autant
d'emplois qui ne sont pas cotisés
tout à l'heure notamment avec
Pierre Laurent on va parler de l'énergie
on va parler de l'exécutif qui a promis
au TPE un prix plafond pour
l'électricité de 280 euros le
mégawattheure est-ce que tous les
boulangers du Lot sont sauvés avec cette
mesure non ils en sont très loin les
boulangers les restaurateurs tous les
artisans qu'est-ce qui vous dit votre
frère il me dit que sa facture
d'électricité va être insupportable dans
les mois qui viennent malgré ça mais
bien sûr ce n'est pas une hausse
raisonnable comme le disait Emmanuel
Macron la semaine dernière c'est une
folie rendez-vous compte qu'il y a des
contrats aujourd'hui de fournitures
d'électricité qui ont été multipliées
par
pas parce que la renégociation va nous
poser des problèmes majeurs comment
est-ce que on va renégocier avec tous
les fournisseurs aujourd'hui moi je veux
que nous devenions
l'état puisque c'est l'État qui va
financer au final il y a une espèce
d'illusion dans tout cela lorsqu'on va
plafonner le prix de l'électricité
lorsqu'on va proposer les renégociations
pour que les fournisseurs baisse
puisqu'on est dans un système totalement
libéralisé le prix revendu c'est l'état
c'est le contribuant c'est ce qu'a dit
Bruno Le Maire vendredi c'est une blague
le cofinancement il faut mettre des mots
sur les choses c'est pas un
cofinancement
le contribuer
la facture et va payer l'impôt qui va
avec je souhaite que nous avons aussi
sur deux mesures radicales et j'assume
cette radicalité la première c'est de
sortir immédiatement du marché européen
de l'électricité voyez-vous je le disais
il y a quelques mois je passais pour une
librairie comme les portugais mais
lorsque je le disais je passais pour
illuminer aujourd'hui il faut que nous
sortions du marché européenne
l'électricité parce que le système de
calcul de l'énergie est invraisemblable
nous achetons nos auditeurs les
spectateurs comprennent nous achetons
sur le marché européen l'électricité de
l'énergie pardon qui est de marcher
boursier l'électricité 4 à 5 fois plus
que le coût de production nous avions
avec le nucléaire sortons immédiatement
du
on casse nos accords on est parfaitement
on est parfaitement capable de la porte
non ça ne veut pas dire qu'on se prive
sortir du marché européen peut nous
permettre de même d'avoir des accords
bilatéraux comme nous l'avions avant le
marché européen de l'énergie avec les
pays voisins mais je veux que nous
allions au-delà et peut-être que nous en
parlerons avec mon collègue sénateur
communiste tout à l'heure à la
reconstruction du pays général de Gaulle
avec les communistes d'ailleurs avaient
considéré que l'énergie comme
l'alimentation était des biens trop
précieux pour être soumis au marché
libéré je fais partie de ceux qui
considèrent qu'on ne doit pas pouvoir
demain échanger en bourse de
l'électricité comme on ne le fait pas
pour l'eau par exemple et je souhaite
que cette matière là ne soit pas une
matière stylée
puisqu'on a des ressources en eau
simplement c'est un marché qui est un
marché protégé et oui pour l'électricité
je souhaite que nous sortions du marché
boursier
oui c'est une manière de nationaliser
mais je n'ai pas de problème avec cela
vous rendez compte où nous en sommes
rendus politique là quand vous faites
toutes tout l'inventaire de ce que vous
venez de nous dire sur les retraites là
sur l'électricité vous pouvez être sur
la même ligne que des communistes est-ce
que vous vous sentez bien chez LR ah oui
je me sens profondément gaulliste ce que
je vous ai dit sur Facebook
ne le pensez et certains qui s'ignorent
alors
et que je tâche de réveiller ou de
révéler mais vous savez aujourd'hui sur
cinq du coup sur la base de notre
résultat et puis vous savez ce qui
compte c'est que nous reparlions en
français est-ce que nos concitoyens ne
se disent pas aujourd'hui que ce système
du marché européen énergie auquel
personne ne comprend rien qui consiste à
caler le prix l'électricité sur celui du
gaz alors que nous étions capables de
produire notre propre électricité et des
raisonnable vous savez ce qui me frappe
beaucoup c'est que le politique est
devenu un petit gestionnaire et que nous
avons devant nous des problèmes
gigantesques
qu'à chaque fois on refuse d'aller à la
racine il y a pas de vision non il n'y a
pas de vie Emmanuel Macron mais pas
seulement nombreuses années les autres
que nous avons mais nous avons contribué
à la situation que nous connaissons
aujourd'hui ce pays ne s'est pas
effondré du jour au lendemain le marché
européen l'électricité la libéralisation
du marché européen l'électricité qui
est-ce qu'il a fait c'est notre famille
politique sous les injonctions de
Bruxelles et de l'Europe voyez une
mesure précise depuis des années la
France existe et à la raison je suis
prêt sur l'hôpital la France résiste à
la raison à libéraliser nos barrages
hydroélectriques si demain on réinvestit
dans nos barrages c'est la meilleure
énergie renouvelable on gagne 20% de
production électrique sur nos barrages
je souhaite que la France dise que
définitivement elle gardera le monopole
d'État sur les barrages hydroélectriques
parce qu'on ne soumet pas à la
concurrence des infrastructures aussi
stratégiques que non
proposez en fait pas du tout nous avons
bâti l'Europe durant des décennies en
ayant pas le marché européen de
l'énergie je souhaite simplement que
d'ailleurs si on veut redevenir européen
on cesse de laisser l'Europe faire
n'importe quoi sur l'hôpital qui était
en crise Emmanuel Macron a présenté ses
vœux vendredi et annoncer toute une
réorganisation et notamment la fin de la
T2A c'est la tarification à l'acte pour
les hôpitaux ça a été instauré par la
droite est-ce que vous approuvez
finalement la fin de cette tarification
je le demandais depuis des années c'est
la droite qu'il a fait c'est Roselyne
Bachelot qui est porté cette mesure là
aujourd'hui nous explique comment il
faut sauver l'hôpital après l'avoir mis
à genoux pardon de le dire comme je le
pense oui il faut sortir la tarification
à l'acte parce que c'était là aussi une
manière au fond de faire rentrer la
spéculation les chiffres là où il ne
devrait pas rentrer mais c'était le cas
c'est une faute de la droite d'avoir
fait ça
à l'époque et à l'époque c'était au
nombre de lits donc on avait énormément
de vie ceux qui m'ont précédé en fait je
pense que ça relève d'une ambiance vous
savez tout ce que nous avons évoqué sur
le marché européen énergie être à la
mode à cette époque là comment quelques
années lorsque je tenais ce discours
être à la mode s'était considéré que le
marché pouvait tout réguler et bien moi
je pense que être gaulliste c'est
peut-être ne pas être toujours à la mode
et rappeler qu'il y a des impératifs ce
soigner avoir accès à notre énergie à
notre alimentation qui doivent être
soumis à des règles c'est la meilleure
manière de faire en sorte que le marché
par ailleurs puisse produire ses effets
positifs la crise de l'accès aux soins
elle est absolument gigantesque je
voudrais attirer votre attention sur un
chiffre depuis des décennies notre pays
a vu la mortalité infantile baissé la
mortalité des bébés depuis des années la
mortalité infantile augmente c'est un
indicateur parmi tant d'autres d'un
échec majeur de l'accès aux soins qui
est pourtant le chantier le plus
dernière question les déserts médicaux
notamment est-ce que vous soutenez une
proposition de loi de Guillaume Garraud
le socialiste pour obliger
l'installation des médecins dans
certains territoires j'ai fait une autre
proposition d'ailleurs ma famille
politique elle a fait je suis pas seul à
l'avoir porté qui n'était pas
l'obligation parce que je pense que
l'obligation ne marchera pas mais qui
était de s'assurer que la dernière année
de médecine pas une de plus la dernière
actuelle soit une année où on envoie nos
jeunes médecins en mission dans les
territoires ruraux ça permet puisque ça
a été voté dans le temps nécessaire
exactement mais je suis certain que non
je ne ferai pas de commentaire sur les
énergies mais je suis certain que nos
médecins seront encore plus efficaces
que nos énergans en préfecture à qui je
ne vois que mal oui nous avons besoin de
remettre de la médecine dans les
territoires eaux ça ne suffira pas
pour les jeunes étudiants qui pensent
que si déjà la dernière année de
médecine est une année en mission on
produira des effets très positifs parce
que ces jeunes là qui rentrent exercés
dans le lot ou ailleurs se rendre compte
qu'au fond sont des endroits où on peut
bien vivre et bien travailler merci
beaucoup Brigitte à la semaine prochaine
bien sûr dans auditions publiques
Vincent roux on va tout de suite vous
rejoindre vous êtes en direct du
figarolive bonsoir mon cher Vincent la
première question d'actualité que vous
avez choisi pour Aurélien Pradier
oui la première question d'actualité
c'est ce choix du gouvernement de
maintenir la chasse le dimanche est-ce
que vous soutenez cette mesure souhaitée
par le gouvernement je n'étais pas
favorable à une journée d'interdiction
de la chasse parce que je pense que
l'enjeu c'est de cohabiter c'est
fondamental il y a des règles à mettre
en place je suis très favorable et le
gouvernement là annoncé à ce que nous
rédigions au plus minimum possible je
serai même favorable à zéro pour ce qui
est de l'alcoolémie et d'ailleurs je
vois moi mes propres chasseurs dans le
Lot qui sont de plus en plus exigeants
sur ce sujet on ne doit pas pouvoir
chasser si on a de l'alcoolémie dans le
sang pour ce qui est de la journée je
pense que c'est une fausse bonne idée
mais nous avons un enjeu de cohabitation
on ne peut pas le sous-estimer il y a
une première étape qui est franchie
est-ce qu'elle sera suffisante je n'en
sais rien c'est un premier point
d'équilibre
Marion mourget face de face à vous bien
sûr à la rédaction du Figaro et plus
précisément au service politique Marion
Moon c'est à vous alors vous l'avez dit
en première partie une réforme des
retraites c'est une réforme de société
une réforme importante est-ce que sur un
texte comme ça un futur numéro 2 de
partie peut être en désaccord avec le
président des républicains puisque Éric
Ciotti a clairement dit qu'il voterait
cette réforme mais je ne vous ai pas dit
que je ne la voterai pas et qu'est-ce
qui vous dit au fond que nous sommes
dans des accords nous avons tous les
deux une vision qui peut parfaitement se
rejoindre voyez-vous dans les points des
lignes rouges que j'ai fixées sur les
petites tensions sur les carrières des
femmes sur la nécessité pour ceux qui
ont commencé à travailler tôt de finir
tôt c'est une préoccupation qui hérite
comme l'ensemble de mes amis ont d'être
juste mais le rôle d'un fond pardon
qu'est-ce qui vous différencie
aujourd'hui d'Éric Ciotti sur la
question et pourquoi cherchez-vous
absolument des différences parce que
vous ne dites pas comme lui vous n'aimez
pas le fait de dire je ces réformes si
les conditions que je pose sont remplies
si les conditions je pose sont remplies
oui mais je dis simplement
qu'aujourd'hui les conditions nous en
sommes loin et que si j'ai voulu les
reposer notamment sur la durée de
cotisation c'est parce que je sais qu'il
y a un long chemin à faire au fond ma
mission
elle est de faire en sorte que les
convictions auxquelles je crois arrivent
à convaincre beaucoup de mes amis
politiques il y a quelque chose qui a
changé dans mon parcours c'est que je ne
suis plus là pour faire du passage en
force comme parfois un peu plus jeune
j'ai pu le faire je suis là pour
convaincre et mes amis sont convaincus
que nous devons reparler aux catégories
les plus populaires il n'y a rien
d'incohérent dans ce que je dis
peut-être qu'il y a des choses un peu
audacieuses mais au fond c'est aussi mon
rôle d'être audacieux il y a aussi des
petites différences vous dites
actuellement pour vous les conditions ne
sont pas remplies avec ces mêmes
conditions encore une fois Éric Ciotti a
indiqué qu'il voterait cette réforme
alors je reformule ma question est-ce
que finalement on peut être loyal et
garder sa liberté de ton quand on
intègre une direction de partie d'abord
je ne sais pas si j'intègre une
direction c'était Éric ce type de de le
décider et pour le reste ni ericciotti
ni moi-même nous sommes des marionnettes
politiques vous aurez sûrement observé
que durant les mois passés durant
l'année précédente j'ai fait entendre
des convictions auxquelles je croyais je
ne fais pas de politique pour des postes
je fais de la politique parce que il y a
des convictions que je souhaite faire
entendre voilà ce qui me guide au
quotidien et je vous assure dans les
convictions que je porte là l'équation
qui consisterait à dire est-ce que si je
dis ça je n'aurai pas le poste en
question etc mais ça ne me traverse pas
l'esprit d'une seule seconde donc si
vous n'arrivez pas mais je n'ai pas
cette tempérament là si vous n'arrivez
pas un accord sur la réforme des
retraites au sein même de votre famille
politique vous pouvez dire je n'intègre
pas la direction ça ne m'intéresse pas
parce que justement le combat que je
porte n'est pas défendu au plus haut les
valeurs c'est bien plus important que
les responsabilités politiques et vous
savez la proposition que j'ai faite à
l'instant sur les 43 annuités qui
doivent primer sur la sur l'âge légal
c'est une proposition que j'ai faite
avec mes collègues en réunion de travail
en décembre et je vous assure que au
sein de notre propre groupe politique
nous avons les uns les autres cheminées
moi-même j'ai cheminé c'est mon rôle de
faire des efforts d'imagination pour que
au fond les valeurs des uns et des
autres se retrouvent
Eric cioti comme tous mes amis y compris
ceux qui parfois sont irrités parce que
je peux dire sont à mon sens convaincus
que la droite ne reviendra pas au
pouvoir si elle ne reparle pas à tous
les Français tous et en particulier les
catégories les plus populaires chaque
heure à son rôle à jouer pour reparler
aux uns et aux autres je sais que mon
chemin c'est de reparler aux électeurs
les plus populaires et là-dessus ça fait
pour vous pas débat qu'il enfin qu'il y
aura une unité demain aux républicain
parce que vous avez notamment une
réunion de groupe puis un séminaire de
rentrée pour parler de cette question
des retraites pour vous il n'y a pas
péril en la demeure entre les
républicains la réforme des retraites
non je pense que nous allons arriver
nous-même à un point de rassemblement et
de même que nous pourrons engager le
bras de fer avec le gouvernement enfin
nous ne sommes pas dociles à droite nous
n'avons jamais été ni Eric Ciotti ni
Bruno retaillod ni moi-même on de
devenir maintenant nous sommes compromis
de cette réforme miniapas encore eu les
débats parlementaires on va quand même
pas de suite dire que tous nous convient
d'autant plus qu'il manque des choses
très importantes moi je le dis à
Elisabeth borne à qui je ne veux pas de
mal et à son gouvernement voilà les
règles que je pose moi-même et pas
seulement moi y compris certaines de mes
amis si ces règles-là sont respectées
notamment sur la durée de cotisation ce
qui serait une évolution majeure je
pense que tout le monde s'y retrouverait
le pire de dans cette réforme là c'est
de vouloir imposer une réforme injuste
et on voit bien qu'il y a une astuce
dans cette réforme qui est de pénaliser
ce qui travaille le plus dur je le
refuse alors vous dites bien engager un
rapport de force avec la première
ministre
est-ce qu'il y a de la place quand même
aux républicain pour ceux qu'on appelle
les Macron compatibles c'est-à-dire ceux
qui aimeraient travailler avec Emmanuel
Macron pour soit un contrat de
gouvernement soit intégrer le
gouvernement et ce que aujourd'hui pour
vous vous dites il faut les écouter aux
républicains et notamment sur cette
question de la réforme des retraites il
faut écouter tout le monde enfin si
certains veulent rentrer au gouvernement
qu'ils se précipitent pourraient rentrer
il prône un rapprochement certains avec
la majorité
ce rapprochement là alors qu'est-ce
qu'il faut en faire c'est plutôt à eux
de prendre le responsabilité c'est vrai
que si vous voulez que je vous réponds
responsabilité mais vous savez vous
m'avez toujours entendu dire que je
trouvais assez insupportable ceux qui
avaient le cul entre deux chaises pardon
pour l'expression vulgaire mais enfin
elle dit ce qu'elle veut dire et si
certains sont tentés par la macronie ou
la du fait que ça me paraît être une
folie à ce stade là de lettres qu'il se
libère de suite mais qu'il ne tente pas
en sous-main de nous embarquer vers des
horizons qui ne seraient pas les nôtres
et si je ne suis pas macroniste ce n’est
pas parce que je n'aime pas Emmanuel
Macron mais c'est parce que le projet de
société qu'il a porté depuis des années
n'est pas le mien voilà c'est une
divergence politique c'est noble une
divergence politique cette divergence là
pour moi elle n'a pas changé
alors
eric ciotique est devenu président des
républicains a fait toute la campagne en
énonçant le fait que Laurent Wauquiez
pour lui était le candidat naturel de la
droite et qu'il fallait l'installer en
2023 alors ça tombe bien on est en 2023
vous dites quoi aujourd'hui il faut
accélérer il faut que Laurent Wauquiez
prenne la parole un peu plus fort et
s'installent comme le candidat naturel
de la droite il faut qu'il continue à
tracer son chemin j'ai dit d'ailleurs je
sais que Eric durant la campagne avait
évolué sur ce sujet que précipiter trop
les choses étaient à mon sens négatif
pour notre candidat je ne pense pas que
2023 soit le bon moment mais nous aurons
le temps de voir venir il faut que
Laurent Wauquiez comme comme d'autres
traces leur sillon et puis vous savez on
fait beaucoup de spéculations sur les
uns et sur les autres mais ce qui
comptera c'est pas seulement la tête du
candidat ce qui comptera c'est le
message qui sera capable de porter la
droite ne réussira pas demain mais au
fond la France ne réussira pas demain
parce que c'est le plus important si
elle ne réussit pas à rassembler tous
les Français on ne peut plus gérer des
clientèles électorales on en a plus et
donc il faut repartir à la conquête moi
j'espère de le renvoquer comme d'autres
qu'ils soient capable de faire preuve
d'imagination politique Jacques Chirac
en 1995 Nicolas Sarkozy en 2007 ont
gagné parce qu'il n'était pas
affreusement conventionnel ils ont gagné
parce qu'il ne répétait pas ce que leur
prédécesseurs avaient répété
éternellement parce qu'ils ont osé pour
l'un la fracture sociale pour l'autre le
travailler plus pour gagner plus il faut
que nous soyons à nouveau des audacieux
la droite plutôt la vie politique sans
imagination c'est une vie politique qui
ne survit pas et vous Laurent Wauquiez à
prendre un peu plus la parole à on
l'entend peu dans le débat actuellement
il avait dit ce sera Marine Le Pen ou
moi je serai une sorte de rempart est-ce
que aujourd'hui vu le contexte vu le
contexte économique et social la colère
des Français vous dites à le renvoquer
si oui tu veux avoir de la place en 2027
il faut s'exprimer aujourd'hui je sais
pas si l'expression publique est
nécessaire
je sais seulement une chose c'est que
nous sommes à droite très loin du but il
faut se le dire nous avons fait moins de
5% à la dernière élection présidentielle
et ce n'est pas lié ouais donc candidats
c'est lié au fait que nous ne portions
plus aucun espoir nous avons tout à
reconstruire et mon seul chemin pour moi
il n'est pas personnel mon seul chemin
désormais il est de contribuer
collectivement parce que j'ai pris ce
goût du collectif à porter un espoir
populaire tout le monde s'y retrouvera
et moi-même avec mon tempérament ma
sensibilité j'y contribué merci Marion
deux questions au parlementaires que
vous êtes
Aurélien prédé d'abord de ma vote du
projet de loi sur les énergies
renouvelables vous le voterez non je ne
le voterai pas je ne voterai pas parce
que j'ai une opposition farouche à ce
qui est prévu en matière d'éolien et
pour moi le chemin qui est engagé est un
chemin de développement de l'éolien
auquel je ne crois pas c'est dit Gérald
Darmanin va présenter celui son projet
de loi sur l'immigration ça a été un
texte important dans les semaines qui
viennent il a multiplié les appels du
pied à la droite tout ce que les LR ont
toujours demandé sur les migrations
proposons
dit-il
et là est-ce que nous verrons je n'ai
pas vu le texte je ne sais pas ce qu'il
y a dedans mais si Gérald darmonin
Darmanin est revenu à ses origines tant
mieux je me suis beaucoup habitué dans
ce texte pour nous avons demandé des
décisions très fermes sur la réduction
massive de l'immigration légale et
légales mais légal en particulier parce
que c'est un vrai sujet nous avons
demandé des mesures fortes sur les
questions d'assimilation qui sont
essentielles et souvent oubliées des
mesures et des textes d'immigration mais
le débat parlementaire reviendra nous
verrons si Gérald Darmanin et sur nos
positions verrons cela mais avec Gérald
Darmanin on a été habitué aux grandes
phrases et aux petits actes je suis pas
certain que ça y Déroche cette fois-ci
vous attendez pour voir bien sûr mais
enfin ce serait absurde même si je n'ai
pas d'amitié particulier pour Gérald
Darmanin compte tenu de son comportement
politique aléatoire ce serait absurde de
vouloir le plus grand mal pour mon pays
d'un mot oui ou non elle vous favorable
à la réintégration des soignants oui
je le suis je vais toujours vous n'avez
pas bougé parce qu'il est temps de
recoller les morceaux dans ce pays face
à vous Pierre Laurent merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous Pierre Laurent sénateur
communiste ben voilà vous avez accepté
aussi le principe du débat et nous vous
en remercions j'imagine que c'est le
débat sur les retraites d'abord qui va
constituer votre principale
interrogation évidemment j'ai envie de
revenir sur le débat des retraites j'ai
écouté monsieur Pradier dans la première
partie de l'émission
Bon vous parlez de Ling rouge moi j'ai
l'impression que vos lignes rouges elles
sont pleines de trous et qu'en fait vous
êtes déjà sur la position
d'érectionnotique et annoncé ce week-end
leur aliment des LR à la réforme parce
que vous construisez tout un discours
pour dire qu'il y aurait une opposition
entre l'allongement de la durée de
cotisation et le report de las légal en
vérité on se dirige vers une réforme où
il faut avoir les trois on va voir le
report de l'âge légal je sais pas si ça
sera 64 ans de choses on va avoir
l'allongement de la durée de cotisation
parce que ça aussi ça sera dans le
projet gouvernemental et donc on va
avoir avec ces deux choses cumulées pour
des millions de Français la baisse de
leur niveau de pension contrairement à
ce qui est annoncé parce que beaucoup
n'arriveront pas à réunir ces conditions
au moment où ils seront obligés de
partir en retraite donc en fait on va
vers une réforme complète complètement
injuste et bon je vois bien comment vous
vous démonez pour essayer de de faire
croire que vous allez installer des
lignes rouges mais en vérité vous vous
installez dans une perspective qui est
une perspective de dégradation massive
du droit à la retraite pour les Français
alors même qu'il y a une colère dans le
pays extrêmement forte parce que
j'imagine que vous rencontrez des
Français comme moi souvent sur le
terrain je ne rencontre pas un seul qui
soit favorable à cette perspective
aujourd'hui peut-être qu'ils existent
ils existent sûrement un peu mais tous
les sondages d'opinion ont l'air de
confirmer ce qu'on entend sur le terrain
c'est à dire une colère très forte
contre ça donc je pense que vous devez
quand même essayer d'assumer avec un peu
plus de franchise ce que votre position
alors que je vous ai entendu
en pointillés je savais ce que je dis là
je le dis depuis des mois effectivement
point que ce ne sont pas du tout des
postures ce que je dis sur les petites
retraites je l'ai toujours dit et vous
savez parfois j'ai été en contre-courant
dans ma propre famille politique lorsque
je disais que l'âge légal n'était pas
l'alpha et l'oméga vous savez à l'époque
certaines mes amis me disaient justement
que maline rouge n'était pas assez rouge
vraiment lorsque je dis que nous avons
un problème aujourd'hui nous aurons des
divergents sur certaines aspects nous
avons un problème c'est que cette
réforme elle va faire de ceux qui ont
commencé à travailler à 20 ans des
grands perdants les 43 annuités de
cotisation c'est la réforme Touraine
c'est une réforme socialiste c'est pas
du tout une réforme de la droite en
l'occurrence ce qui vont commencer à
travailler en même temps qui sont les
travailleurs que vous rencontrez comme
moi qui vont être cassés par le travail
arriver à 60 ans ou à 62 ans je ne veux
pas qu'il soit pénalisé et croyez moi
avec franchise si je dis que c'est une
ligne rouge pour moi c'est que c'est une
ligne
pas le problème quelqu'un qui a 20 ans
partir donc avec une carrière complète
en supposant 43 années à 63 ans déjà un
an de plus que l'âge légal actuel je
prends
et aujourd'hui et aujourd'hui et
aujourd'hui vous avez des gens
effectivement qui commence très tôt et
il faut traiter effectivement pour les
carrières longues la possibilité même de
partir beaucoup plus tôt vous savez que
nous continuons à défendre le principe
d'un départ à la retraite à 60 ans
et pour les autres tout ce par exemple
qui vont partir à 20 ans à 21 ans qui
vont commencer à travailler pardon à 20
ans à 21 ans 22 ans avec votre propre
système même on dépasse les 64 ans parce
que si on commence soyons avec 43 années
de cotisations tout le monde comprend ça
on finit à 65 je vais essayer de
préciser ce que je vous disais les 43
annuités c'est la perspective de la
réforme Touraine tant que nous ne sommes
pas à l'horizon de la réforme Touraine
on est sur 42 annuités et je ne souhaite
pas que on aille au-delà de la réforme
droite donc c'est d'abord 42 amités et
ensuite 43 mais là où nous pouvons nous
accorder c'est que on a un point sur
l'âge légal de départ à la retraite je
ne souhaite pas qu'on le réduise je
souhaite que ce soit la durée de
cotisation qui prime pour ceux qui ont
commencé à travailler après 21 ans ça ne
change rien puisque la durée de
cotisation les fait atterrir à peu près
à l'âge légal aujourd'hui là où nous
avons un sujet et c'est un point
d'accord que je peux avoir avec
certaines vos amis politiques ce sont
pour les carrières longues on a un
chemin important à franchir encore parce
que nos téléspectateurs le savent
sûrement pour obtenir une carrière
longue il faut avoir travaillé avant 16
ans avant 18 ans avant 20 ans et avoir
cumulé un centre de trimestre souvent on
y arrive pas je souhaite qu'on soit
beaucoup plus souple sur ce sujet et je
le redis et vous pouvez vous avez ma
parole et mon engagement devant vous
mais aussi devant ceux qui nous écoutent
je ne céderai pas sur cette question de
ceux qui ont commencé à travailler tout
parce que c'est une question qu'on se
retrouve sur cette question précise mais
vous ne pouvez pas dire plus vous
allonger la durée de cotisation plus
vous dégradez la possibilité d'accéder à
une retraite dans de bonnes conditions
nous sommes d'accord quand c'est le
contraire de ce que vous avez dit c'est
tout à l'heure tout à l'heure les
générations précédentes ont eu des
carrières hachées ça sera moins vrai
demain c'est exactement l'inverse les
générations précédentes c'est parce
qu'on a eu souvent des des emplois fixes
dans la même entreprise pendant très
longtemps c'était le cas de mes parents
et d'autres et cetera de mes des gens
autour de moi lorsque je leur
qu'aujourd'hui au contraire ce qui
caractérise le monde du travail c'est
les carrières hachées
etc c'est utile plus vous allez durcir
les conditions d'accès à la retraite
plus vous allez dégrader l'accès mais je
voudrais ajouter une autre chose vous
permettez qu'il réponde quand même
on a un point de désaccord notamment sur
l'âge légal et ça c'est pas très grave
c'est plutôt une bonne nouvelle pour
vous et pour moi là où je pense vraiment
qu'on peut avoir un combat je sais pas
si les communs dans tous les cas dans
l'hémicycle nous aurons ces combats là
ce sont pour les carrières longues je
souhaite y être attentif autant que vous
l'êtes lorsque je parlais des carrières
hachées tout à l'heure je parlais des
femmes la génération de mes parents de
mes grands-parents avaient moins de
systèmes aujourd'hui que nous avons
aujourd'hui dans les carrières des
femmes et là on a mais encore
considérable à réaliser l'écart vous en
serez d'accord de pension de retraite
entre des femmes des hommes est entre 30
et 40%. c'est à dire que c'est encore
plus grand que l'écart de salaire tout
au long de leur carrière c'est
absolument gigantesque sur ça je
souhaite que nous avons sur la question
mais moi je ne rentrerai vous vous
assumez pardon vous assumez vous
allongez la durée de cotisation quand
Pierre Laurent dit que elle n'est pas
allongée je souhaite que nous câlions
sur la réforme Touraine
sauf que nous n'avons pas besoin d'une
nouvelle réforme pour voir son entrée à
l'application la réforme Touraine portée
par les socialistes
il y a quand même été porté par la
gauche enfin pardon pas par les
communistes
cette réforme Touraine je souhaite qu'on
la conserve telle qu'elle est qu'on
aille pas au-delà parce que c'est
inutile et là où nous avons un sujet
considérable ce sont les 8 milliards
d'euros de pension des validité que
j'évoquais tout à l'heure je sais que
votre famille politique le revendique et
vous avez raison on sait aussi qu'on va
avoir un effet de bord le rapport de la
dresse nous dit que si on augmente
seulement l'âge légal sans aucune autre
mesure on va passer de 8 milliards à 12
parfois un peu plus peut-être 13
milliards d'euros de pension
d'invalidité et ce n'est pas le rapport
au travail que vous souhaitez ça fait la
journée avec l'autre remarque que je
voulais vous faire c'est qu'en fait
c'est très fort son grand tort c'est
qu'elle passe à côté du grand sujet des
Français parce que le grand sujet des
Français aujourd'hui c'est l'emploi
c'est les salaires c'est la qualité de
la production et des services et des
services publics en particulier si nous
nous attaquons à ces questions là c'est
à dire si nous créons tous les emplois
qui manquent dans le pays et on sait
qu'aujourd'hui il en manque partout et
beaucoup donc dans les services publics
mais aussi dans la production
industrielle tout on parle de ça tous
les jours si on s'attaque à ça nous
n'avons plus de problèmes de financement
des retraites donc en vérité la réforme
qui joue actuellement pour dégrader et
les conditions de retraite c'est une
réforme qui va faire payer
au retraités aux futurs retraités
une absence de politiques sérieuse en
matière d'emploi en matière de salaire
en matière de de qualité d'embauche pour
la production et les services
vous comprenez on va dégrader les
conditions d'accès aux retraites aux
infirmières alors que la question c'est
que si on embauchait et si on formait si
on embauchait toutes les infirmières la
solution il faut les former il faut mais
la formation des infirmières en quelques
années ça peut avancer très vite je peux
avancer très vite et très fortement et
si on fait ça et même si ça prend 10 ans
vu que les niveaux de déficit sont en
vérité très faible aujourd'hui au niveau
des retraites on trouvera les conditions
d'un équilibre complet du régime etc et
si on le fait dans tous les domaines si
on ne fait pas ça on va cumuler un
manque de recettes qui va continuer à
s'aggraver avec une dégradation des
conditions d'accès à la retraite et bien
je partage votre vision alors à ce
moment là il faut pas faire cette
réforme il faut voter contre il faut
penser à autre chose rassurez-vous on
aura aussi des points de désaccord mais
si on s'arrête à l'instant
historiquement on a eu la droite et les
communistes beaucoup de divergences et
on a encore et tant mieux pour vous
comme pour moi mais sur la valeur du
travail je pense qu'il nous est arrivé
d'avoir le même respect de l'effort et
le respect des travailleurs et vous avez
très tout à fait raison de dire que
aujourd'hui le déséquilibre de notre
système n'est pas seulement lié à une
question démographique il est lié au 35
heures au fait qu'on travaille moins
qu'il y a moins d'emplois qu'on a des
industrialisé ce pays qu'on a entre 4 et
500 000 emplois vacants dans les
secteurs en tension etc etc on sera pas
d'accord sur les solutions solutions que
je proposais de travailler l'essentiel
oui le constat c'est important lorsque
je n'ai pas on règlerait le problème des
retrait je le reconnais totalement
les conditions d'accès et même on
pourrait progressivement
compris à mes amis politiques nous ne
pouvons pas
appréhender la réforme des retraites
seulement par le petit bout de la
lorgnette il faut aussi revoir
l'ensemble du monde du travail et quand
je propose la semaine de 38 heures en
quatre jours on aura des désaccords sur
l'idée mais je sais ce que vous allez en
dire mais de mon point de vue de droite
vous permet elle permet aussi de redire
qu'il nous faut mais quand produire
davantage moi je suis d'accord sur une
idée c'est que la France globalement
peut mieux travailler et plus travailler
et plus travailler si on fait travailler
ceux qui ne travaillent pas qui sont au
chômage à qui on impose des carrières
hachées à qui on ne donne pas de travail
après 50 ans parce qu'on les vire des
entreprises mais pas faire
continuellement travailler plus ceux qui
sont au travail et c'est à nouveau ce
que vous proposez alors vous vous le
proposez d'une manière différente mais
vos recettes c'est toujours les mêmes
c'est continuer à faire travailler plus
ceux qui travaillent je vous en laissant
sur le carreau tous ceux que je vous
assure accéder au travail je vous assure
que si on recèle les recettes que si
vous permettez les recettes que je
propose sont un peu un peu nouvelles
perturbant mais y compris vous savez
pour mes propres amis politiques sauf
que j'appartiens à une génération qui
est une génération qui a soupé des 35
heures et d'ailleurs qu'on a compris que
les 35 heures donner un confort de vie
mais ne permettait pas de profiter de
ses loisirs parce que on ne pouvait pas
gagner davantage et donc j'ai beaucoup
de ma génération qui cherchent à pouvoir
travailler davantage portrait le
jugement que vous voulez là-dessus pour
avoir un salaire meilleur pour mieux
faire vivre leur famille et de pouvoir
organiser leur temps de travail
différemment c'est pas possible pour
toutes les entreprises j'en ai
conscience mais je pense que c'est un
sujet que nous devons explorer comme
d'ailleurs la Belgique est en train de
le faire de manière assez intéressante
c'est ce que la droite a travaillé plus
pour gagner plus c'est ce que la droite
de Nicolas Sarkozy essayer de faire
croire aux Français
à ce qu'attendre les Français parce que
dans énormément de filières les gens
s'épuisent au travail
et aujourd'hui ce qu'il demande c'est
pouvoir au contraire pouvoir respirer en
plus depuis la pandémie il y a beaucoup
de gens qui s'intéressent sur le sens
qui s'interroge sur le sens de leur
travail donc les gens veulent pouvoir
travailler mieux pour pouvoir respirer
dans leur vie et gagner correctement
leur vie et si on s'occupait de d'aller
dans cette direction et bien on
donnerait du travail à plus de monde et
on arriverait à produire mieux la forme
de meilleures services à la société donc
on travaillerait ou bien collectifs je
crois que la faute originelle de la
gauche mais d'ailleurs votre président
de parti
l'a dit assez justement je trouve la
faute originelle de la gauche et d'avoir
dégradé la valeur du travail vous savez
comme moi parce que vous rencontrez des
travailleurs tous les jours je le sais
que le travail je le sais
et c'est pour ça votre temps oui c'est
vrai c'est vrai que Monsieur Roussel l'a
dit et je suis d'accord avec lui sur ce
point-là il nous faut retrouver la
valeur du travail parce que c'est ce qui
à l'époque de la préguerrement de la
reconstruction a permis d'irriguer de
nos systèmes de solidarité on aura des
désaccords sur les solutions mais on
peut avoir un point d’accord pour dire
que c'est par le travail la
revalorisation du travail et de l'effort
qu'on peut assumer toutes les formes de
solidaire pendant qu'on travaille des
bonnes conditions de travail un droit à
la retraite méritée suffisamment tôt
pour pouvoir profiter d'une retraite en
bonne santé parce que on parle du temps
dont on dispose après la retraite mais
le problème c'est d'avoir un temps de
repos en bonne santé
parce qu'on sait que les retraités sont
extrêmement actifs dans la société par
exemple dans la vie associative nous
sommes d'accord je reviens sur 38 heures
sur 4 jours quel est l'intérêt l'intérêt
est associé deux valeurs qui pour moi
sont importantes la valeur de l'effort
et du travail aujourd'hui on travaille
autour de 36 heures en moyenne dans
notre pays un peu plus passer à 38
heures c'est gagné deux heures de plus
donc de salaire mais aussi de
cotisations et donc de systèmes qui
irrigueront de cotisation qui est réglée
dans le système c'est le travail est
plus et les quatre jours parce que la
société a changé et que je le vois bien
aujourd'hui y compris dans des grandes
entreprises industrielles j'en ai une
dans le Lot qui dans l'industrie
agroalimentaire ils sont en train de
travailler sur cette aménagement des
semaines et je ne veux pas qu'il n'y ait
que les cadres qui puissent bénéficier
de cela ce qui est déjà le cas souvent
aujourd'hui avec des semaines de 4 jours
on vous dites le rapport au travail plus
pour une qualité de vie supérieure c'est
travailler plus gagner plus et
travailler mieux alors je sais que
parfois ça peut perturber y compris à
droite mais au fond je crois que ça
correspond aux aspirations notre société
sans sacrifier une valeur fondamentale
que les 35 heures avaient sacrifié c'est
la valeur du travail et de
l'efforts
des 35 heures de des créations d'emplois
qui devaient aller avec c'est pareil ça
c'est une théorie à l'hôpital on n'a pas
voulu on a fait les 35 heures mais on
n'a pas voulu créer les emplois
parce que c'est une chimie aujourd'hui
le partage du temps de travail
ne produit pas plus d'emploi et surtout
ça a un stylé dans la société l'idée que
le travail était un problème je ne le
crois pas d'où vient cette idée qui vous
parle de ça ici personne ne vous dit que
le travail est très bien mais lorsqu'on
défend le français le travail le travail
est on peut le rendre intéressant on
peut le rendre épanouissant on n'est pas
obligé d'épuiser les gens au travail on
n'est pas obligé de toujours intensifier
le travail c'est même ça d'ailleurs
toutes les études le montrent qui
dégradent souvent la qualité du travail
parce que les gens quand ils commencent
à être épuisés fatigués stressés qu'il
ne peuvent plus se concentrer sur le
travail produisent un mauvais travail
allez interroger des gens dans les
entreprises ou dans l'espace qu'il vous
diront tous pourront travailler
correctement
comme pour répondre à Elisabeth
Martichoux à l'instant cette idée-là
elle sort pas de ma tête un jour de rêve
d'aller collerie forcée non cette idée
là elle bien des discussions que j'ai
avec les entreprises avec les Français
depuis des années
l'installe déjà y compris industriels et
me disent tester cette idée tout le
monde ne pourra pas le faire mais
comment
ce ne sont pas ceux qui je discute
le travail je respecte beaucoup les
chefs malheureusement sur l'énergie
j'avais une question mais là on sera
peut-être un peu plus convergent parce
que je vous ai entendu tout à l'heure
on est dans une situation catastrophique
à mon avis on n'a rien vu parce que les
prix de l'énergie sont en train
d'étrangler les foyers mais les TPE les
PME les collectivités locales qui
ferment savent pas comment donc il faut
s'attaquer sérieusement le problème moi
je crois que le cœur du problème vous
l'avez évoqué tout à l'heure c'est qu'il
faut retrouver il faut se déconnecter du
marché européen de l'électricité actuel
pourquoi parce que nous avons des prix
qui n'ont rien à voir avec les prix de
production dans notre propre pays alors
que nous sommes des producteurs
d'électricité qui sont capables de
satisfaire leurs besoin même si on a
besoin aussi d'interconnexion mais là
dessus je pense qu'on est d'accord
nous nous allons soumettre avec mon ami
Fabien gay une proposition de résolution
européenne sur ce thème jeudi prochain
au Sénat je crois pas que vos amis des
LR soit décidée à la voter à cette
heure-là mais on va essayer de les
convaincre donc si vous avez un peu
d'amis dans le groupe des Républicains
vous pouvez peut-être leur conseiller de
voter parce que c'est exactement la
proposition que nous faisons parce que
quand j'entends Bruno Le Maire se
satisfaire du fait qu'à 280 euros
du mégawator on devrait être satisfait
on se moque du monde je veux dire on est
à 5 fois le prix de production de
l'électricité en France oui il y a
convergence mais sûrement parce que
historiquement on a fait partie de ceux
qui avons fondé aussi la souveraineté
les gaullistes et les communistes
fondaient la souveraineté énergétique de
notre pays il y a convergence sur la
sortie du marché européenne
l'électricité il y a convergence
sûrement sur le fait de dire que on ne
peut pas continuellement soumettre la
spéculation boursière la question de
publicité et puis il y a une autre
convergence parce que c'est un combat
que nous avions mené en commun ici à
l'Assemblée nationale je m'en souviens
sur le refus de mettre en concurrence
nos barrages hydroélectriques qui sont
le patrimoine des Français et qui
relèvent notre souveraineté
je pense que la France devrait cesser de
se laisser embarquer dans des
négociations qui n'en finissent pas il
faut dire à la Commission européenne que
pour la France cette question est
tranchée nous ne toucherons pas à la
maîtrise publique des barrages
hydroélectriques point final il faut
être un peu ferme sur cette question
c'est de travailler au corps les
sénateurs et l'Air Force voter
l'approprier ça peut être réglé ce
problème
national jeudi après-midi
on quitte les débats passionnants sur la
souveraineté énergétique question
d'actualité est-ce que selon vous
Aurélien Pradier Noël le grec doit
démissionner de son poste de la
Fédération française de football après
ce que tout le monde présente comme un
nouveau dérapage au sujet de ses propos
concernant Zinédine Zidane d'abord il
devra avoir honte parce que j'ai trouvé
ça absolument misérable et pour tout
vous dire je trouve que c'est une parole
abrutie voilà pardon le traite pas
d'abruti lui-même mais je considère que
sa parole lait et quand on a des propos
de comptoirs comme ce lieu comme ceux
qu'il a eu je pense qu'il est temps de
prendre sa retraite oui il y a des
sujets sur lesquels je suis favorable à
ce qu'on avance l'âge de départ à la
retraite
il doit démissionner
juste alors question subsidiaire on
vient de l'apprendre pendant que vous
faisiez cette émission Hugo Lloris
annonce sa retraite vous regrettez cette
décision
de l'équipe de France
mondiale merci donc je suis certain
qu'il a mérité sa retraite et que il
transmettra le flambeau à d'autres
joueurs qui nous feront rêver bon alors
moi aussi j'ajoute ma petite question ma
pierre à l'édifice
Zidane ce serait bien qu'il entraîne un
jour l'équipe de France
est-ce qu'il en a la volonté je n'en
sais rien est-ce qu'un excellent joueur
mythique peut être un excellent
entraîneur de l'équipe de France
sûrement c'est une décision très
personnelle en réalité je ne suis pas
certain même qu'il en est la volonté en
tous les cas il fait partie des hommes
et comme d'autres femmes d'ailleurs nous
ont fait rêver et ça c'est un point
commun que nous avons tous les Français
par des personnalités qui nous font
rêver ça fait longtemps que ça nous est
pas arrivé d'avoir des personnalités
qu'on respecte juste parce qu'elles nous
font
ultime question pour vous aurait porte
de l'uniforme à l'école à tous les
élèves c'est non a dit le ministre de
l'éducation nationale la semaine
dernière selon lui ça ne règle pas ça ne
réglera pas le problème parce qu'un
uniforme on peut le customiser on peut
le personnaliser en revanche il est
d'accord pour les établissements si les
conseils d'établissement sont d'accord
le décide au cas par cas vous aviez fait
une proposition dans ce champ est-ce que
ce en même temps si je puis dire 2018
éducation nationale vous satisfait je
souhaite
se retrouve donc la semaine prochaine
sur LCP et Public Sénat à 19h30 bonne
soirée à tous
[Musique]